so the republican party should
appreciate and cherish its heritage the
anti-slavery party the civil rights
party and today we continue that by
being a party of individual freedom and
opportunity
what is your day job when you're not
writing books
i speak to republican organizations and
let me tell you the website for the book
is back to is
republicanbasics.com
www.republicanbasics.com
and people can contact me there and i'm
just so gratified that my message is
starting to take off within the
republican party that again republicans
should know and appreciate their
heritage as a party especially with
regard to civil rights achievement
michael sack thanks very much my
pleasure
slavery was used to create tiffany and
company brown university and lehman
brothers according to journalists and
pharaoh joel lang and jennifer frank
they detail these and other examples of
how the north profited from slavery in
their new book complicity
this event from the new york historical
society lasts about an hour
[Applause]
i'm delighted to welcome anne faro joe
lang and jennifer frank to the
historical society to discuss their book
complicity how the north promoted
prolonged and profited from slavery
by examining the institution through a
national economic lens this book reveals
that the north's most prominent people
and businesses were undeniably linked to
slavery and that in fact their success
was contingent upon the unpaid labor of
millions of slaves
part two of the historical society's
exhibition on slavery in new york
opening in november 2006 we'll examine
this issue in depth specifically with
respect to new york city and state i
hope that you visit part one
or have already visited it and will
return which is currently on display uh
this exhibition this first part of the
exhibition focuses on the lives and
legacies of the enslaved and as i said i
hope you've already seen it but if you
haven't i hope that you will feel
compelled to
to visit it and also to return
next fall for part two
the information and complicity was first
published in the hartford current
america's oldest continuously published
newspaper where ms farrow mr lang and
miss frank are reporters
and pharaoh was the lead writer for the
special slavery issue of northeast the
current sunday magazine
and she later journeyed to sierra leone
to report and write the story of
connecticut's involvement in the african
slave trade
joe lang has been a reporter and editor
at the current since 1968 and he won the
new england society of newspaper editors
master reporter award for career
achievement
and jennifer frank has been editor of
northeast since 2001 and was editor of
the special issue on slavery
the formal program this evening will be
followed by question and answer session
there will be staff on the floor with
microphones to ensure that the entire
audience can hear your questions
following the program i hope all of you
will join us for a reception in our
great hall
our speakers will be available to answer
additional questions and also to sign
copies of complicity which is available
in our museum shop
now as we begin the programs i hope that
you'll make sure your cell phones are
turned off thank you very much for
joining us
thank you so much to the new york
historical society for having us here we
are delighted to be here and
delighted with the exhibit which i also
urge you to see
on a saturday afternoon in december in
1860
more than two 000 businessmen and
politicians gathered in lower manhattan
for an extraordinary meeting
characterized by nothing less than panic
everyone knew that the election of the
anti-slavery lincoln the month before
could push south carolina out of the
union and that the other southern states
could soon follow
after less than 100 years of nationhood
the disintegration of the united states
seemed a very real possibility
some of the most prominent new yorkers
were present that winter afternoon not
to mention some of the wealthiest men in
the country
they included
william astor
son of john jacob astor the nation's
first millionaire
august belmont a wall street banker and
former agent for the rothschilds
belmont had married the daughter of
commodore perry and his interest in
horse breeding had led to the creation
of the belmont stakes
there were merchants retailers shipping
magnates newspaper editors senators and
even even former u s president millard
fillmore
all gathered on pine street a stone's
throw from wall street
as the shadows deepened that day the
crowd heard speaker after speaker direct
their pleas to what could seem today to
be an unlikely subject
the owners of southern plantations
southern planters should
consider their duties to that part of
their northern brethren whose sympathies
have always been with southern rights
declared one businessman to the crowd
we will not review the dark history of
the aggression and insult visited upon
you by abolitionists asserted a former
senator
of course the entreaties of speakers at
the pine street meeting did nothing to
avert secession or war and in retrospect
they seem almost pathetic
but today
nearly 150 years later
the gathering shows if nothing else
that in the days before the civil war
the mason-dixon line was little more
than a cartographer's conceit
that north and south was a false divide
in fact less than a month after pine
street after the southern states had
begun their exodus from the union
the mayor of new york urged his city to
secede along with the south
the explanation of these seemingly
incredible events is relatively simple
if you did what my co-authors and i
largely did in researching and writing
complicity
we followed the money
[Music]
anxiety that thousands of new yorkers
felt over the prospects of losing the
south had its roots in one word
cotton
which was grown by millions of slaves
and which as early as 40 years before
pine street already made up 40 percent
of new york city's exports
in the decades before the civil war in
fact cotton had become the single most
important source of new york's fast
expanding wealth and power
by the outbreak of the civil war the
southern states were producing close to
70 percent of the world's cotton
in the last growing season before the
war the us produced 2.3
billion pounds
sending about half to great britain's
thousands of textile factories
england was essentially clothing the
western world using southern slave grown
cotton
not only did cotton make up a huge
portion of new york exports it helped
create the wealth that in turn attracted
hundreds of other businesses to lower
manhattan
following the money you can clearly see
19th century new york city as the center
of a financial universe
attracting a multitude of businesses
all of which in some way depended on the
cotton plant
and of course on slavery
think about it
someone had to build ships to transport
the cotton
a huge industry sprung up around the
south street seaport
the streets of manhattan were filled
with carpenters sail makers makers of
nautical instruments stevedores riggers
dock makers etc etc
as for the cotton industry
someone had to finance it
new york became home to banks and other
financial institutions that helped
southern plantation owners buy land and
cotton seeds and gins and other
equipment
planters also needed these banks to help
them survive between the start of the
growing season and the time they could
sell their crop
new york banks also help plantation
owners buy the labor to work that land
slaves were often bought on credit
but there was more
every summer new york city became a
mecca
its hotels were filled with southerners
who were there not only to escape the
heat but to buy
by what
absolutely anything they wanted
the national and international cotton
trade had attracted hundreds of
businesses that packed the streets of
lower manhattan helping to turn the city
into the shoppers paradise that we all
know and love today
learning about the first half of the
19th century in new york city
was a little like reading the name tags
at a high school reunion
i know that guy
oh there's so and so
here are some names you'll all recognize
there were those three brothers
who used to be cotton brokers in
montgomery alabama before moving to new
york and helping to establish the new
york cotton exchange
you know the lehman brothers
jp morgan whose father a banker and
cotton broker in london
arranged for the future industrialist to
study the cotton trade in the south
before jp began his own business career
and he did quite well i think
john jacob astor ships like those of
many successful merchant shippers also
carry tons of cotton
cotton's rich threads can even be traced
to an ambitious young man who yearned to
open a fancy goods store in new york and
who did so on broadway in 1837
after getting a stake from his father
who operated a cotton mill in
connecticut
you may have heard of the business
started by charles tiffany
and of course mayor bloomberg doesn't
live at gracie mansion
but i wonder if he's even aware that it
was built by a cotton merchant
gracie mansion was originally the summer
home of archibald gracie a merchant
prince who traded in many things
including of course cotton
archibald actually lost his shirt and
abandoned his home
and his son and grandson eventually left
the city from mobile alabama to become
yes cotton merchants
on the cusp of the civil war
the population of enslaved people in
america was about four million of whom
more than half were involved with
growing cotton
and if you can continue to follow the
money you'll see that cotton was
important not just to new york but to
the entire north
it powered america's industrial
revolution which like its british
counterpart began with the textile
industry
this introduced of course a whole new
pantheon of recognizable names
lowell
lawrence
cabot
these still prominent families
helped establish or build the
institutions that helped define america
like mass general hospital
harvard
williams
not to mention railroads banks and
insurance companies
the very spine of the nation's economy
had direct and important links to the
mammoth cotton industry and of course to
slavery
because
slave grown cotton was more than a
profitable crop
it was more than an extremely profitable
crop
it was the national currency
the product most responsible for
america's initial explosive growth
what's more it helped to create a nation
that was attractive to people throughout
the world
people everywhere very quickly looked to
america as a place where they could
thrive
this was and is an image in large part
born out of the fact that the free labor
of millions of people provided america
with an economic slingshot just as the
country was getting started
slaves helped create america's golden
image and golden reality
the paradox of course is that even
though slavery divided america and led
to a terrible civil war it also united
us
certainly economically
so
maybe you can understand the panic of
those merchants on that winter afternoon
what would happen to them what would
happen to new york if there were an end
to slavery
well the editor of an influential
southern business journal actually had
an answer to this
when james deboe was asked by the times
of london
what would new york be without slavery
he replied
the ships would rot at her docks
grass would grow in wall street and
broadway
and the glory of new york like that of
babylon and rome
would be numbered with the things of the
past
this all becomes clear and obvious even
if you follow the money
[Applause]
[Music]
i am assuming that the great crowd here
is testimony to the importance of the
exhibit outside as well as
to our own celebrity but
it's so wonderful to see so many people
my co-authors and i all had different
reactions to the history of slavery we
were so late in discovering
for myself the single overarching
revelation was at how much slavery had
to do with shaping our nation
at the same time that our national
narrative ignored it
by national narrative i mean the public
one that celebrates the westward
movement of pilgrims and pioneers
from sea to shining sea
when you stop to think about it even the
geography of slavery in its simplest
dimension runs horizontally like the
mason-dixon line
dividing north from south
and white history
from black exploitation
but what about specific surprises
first there was the slave trade the
actual traffic in african flesh
having grown up in rhode island i
already knew that the wealth of the
illustrious brown family
founders of brown university was tainted
by slave trading
but i viewed the stories about the
browns as just another part of rhode
island's renegade folklore
religious outcasts mafia kingpins
corrupt politicians slave traders it was
all of a piece more entertaining than
anything
only in working on this project that i
learned how important the slave trade
was to rhode island
it sent nearly a thousand legal slave
voyages to africa in the decades before
and after the american revolution
the first wheel of commerce
is what a new newport minister once
called it
and rhode island kept sending slave
voyages illegally for a time after the
trade was banned in 1808
nor had i ever heard a word about james
the wolf who lived on the other side of
narragansett bay in bristol
the wolf commanded a whole fleet of
slave ships and personally captain son
the wolf was once accused of murder for
throwing a sixth slave overboard
the charge
which might have been brought against
any number of slave ship captains was
never prosecuted
nor did it damage the wolf's reputation
much
he became an oligarch and probably the
only slave ship captain ever elected to
the united states senate
when he went to washington in 1820 he
took his african-born household slaves
with him
one of the wolves few contributions as a
senator was to introduce legislation
that prevented the british navy from
boarding american merchant ships
suspected of carrying slaves
it became crucially important years
later when new york city became the hub
of an illegal trafficking slaves so
brazen that newspapers condemned the
officials who abetted it as quote pimps
of piracy unquote sailing under the
protection of the american flag these
larger ships carried cargos of 800 and
even 1 000 slaves to brazil and later
cuba
the illegal trade finally ended after
the outbreak of the civil war when
president lincoln refused to spare the
life of the only american ever ordered
executed for slave trading
he was nathaniel gordon from portland
maine
captain of the slave ship erie from new
york
i first came across gordon's name in a
footnote in w.e.b du bois's treatise on
attempts to suppress the african slave
trade
published more than a century ago
another forgotten kind of slave trade
was that in free blacks and escaped
slaves kidnapped from northern states
and seoul south
this other other ground this other
underground railroad as it has been
called
operated for roughly a half century and
its conductors were often organized
gangs
the most notorious was led by a woman
named patty cannon
she was an outsized figure said to be so
strong
she could jerk a sack of grain to her
shoulder or a grown man office off his
feet
but cannon or her minions murdered
children when necessary
mostly they preferred to sell their prey
one of the hunting grounds they favored
was the philadelphia waterfront
the law finally began to pursue the
cannon gang after some of the dozen or
more use it kidnapped from philadelphia
in the summer of 1825
showed up for sale in mississippi
most of the gang got away cannon herself
was caught but not until 1829
after a plow [ __ ] stumbled into the
shallow grave of one of her victims a
child
buried on a farm she once occupied on
the delaware maryland state line
the slave trades legal or illegal like
slavery itself could not have flourished
unless white americans were free to
regard blacks as degraded beings at once
childlike and dangerous
thomas jefferson advanced that view by
speculating in his notes on the state of
virginia that blacks might be
biologically inferior
by the mid-1800s american scientists had
transformed jefferson's musings into a
full-fledged race theory
its pioneering genius was the
philadelphia physician samuel george
morton
who collected human skulls by the
hundred to compare their brain size
eventually morton and his disciples one
was the famed harvard professor lewis
agassi
reached the only conclusion their reason
allowed
god had created the races of mankind as
separate species
and blacks were the most inferior of all
[Music]
jenny and joel and i are particularly
proud to be here
during a week when we honor the memory
and courage of rosa parks
[Music]
my colleagues and i wrote a book about
how northern agency fostered and
solidified american slavery
most of our chapters address the actions
of powerful white men
but the heart of this work for me
was the desire to understand the
experience of captive people
among my chapters were those on venture
smith who was a slave in the new world
for almost 30 years
the 1741 manhattan rebellion when black
men fought back against their bondage
with arson fires and connecticut's ivory
trade which enslaved black african men
and women
in researching these and other chapters
i sought to understand the very
particular quality of suffering and
isolation endured by enslaved people
new york captive austin stewart wrote
after becoming a free man
slavery anywhere it exists is just
slavery
and there was never anywhere a better or
more benign version of enslavement
despite what i read in the new england
histories
but to have been captives in the
colonies
and slaves to people who often had less
new world history than the captives
themselves
must have been especially painful
the enslaved black men in 1741 manhattan
must have wondered why they were the
permanent outsiders
they were a third of the workforce
a highly skilled workforce by the way
yet they were still in the words of one
eighteenth
eighteenth-century judge those black
devils
court justice daniel horse mandan's
detailed accounting of the 1741
conspiracy trials was designed to do
several things
to document the proceedings of the court
to demonstrate the guilt of the black
defendants
and to reassure white new yorkers that
their social system was safe and their
labor system intact
what horse mandem did not mean to do and
what he did for me most profoundly
was to illuminate the plight of not only
the accused but all captive new yorkers
on trial for their lives knowing that
conviction meant the gallows or even
worse death of the stake
the accused men were without legal
counsel and they faced a court that
loathed the sight of them
you are furnished with all the
necessaries of life
meat drink and clothing without care in
a much better manner than you could
provide for yourselves were you at
liberty said horse mandan as he
sentenced to men to be burned alive
what then could prompt you to undertake
so vile so wicked so monstrous so
hellish a scheme as to murder and
destroy your benefactors
on the day he was arrested
cuff philip see the first of two men to
be burned
spoke to a jailhouse informant who later
testified that cuff knew quote he was to
suffer death
and that he would not say anything more
but sat in his cell reading and weeping
cuff and quack roosevelt who died
together were real to me
they did not want to be slaves
like the african men who had rebelled
against their bondage in the same part
of manhattan in 1712
they wanted to own their own lives
quack was burned for having set fire to
fort george
though already part of a group of
enslaved men plotting to set fires in
the city
it appears that he set fire to the fort
on march 17 1741
on a furious impulse when he was
thwarted in an attempt to visit his wife
his wife barbara was also a captive and
a cook at the fort
quack roosevelt's dying words as the
fires surrounded the stake where he was
chained were that his wife knew nothing
of the plot
what horse mandon conveys in his
narrative and this was not his intention
was the despair of new york's captives
and the ferocity with which they hated
their enslavement
changed to a stake and with flames
leaping around him
a black man named harry screamed out
that he would not confess because what
good would it do
there are a number of first-hand
accounts left to us by people who were
enslaved in the north
in the course of working on complicity
i went often to their words so that i
could be reconnected to the suffering
heart of their experience
venture smith was born the son of a king
in africa but he was a slave in new
england and on new york's fishers island
for nearly 30 years
he dictated an extraordinary account of
his life to a revolutionary war soldier
and school teacher named elisha niles
and though it is a document of only 30
pages it contains a powerful retelling
of his idyllic childhood in freedom
the long misery of captivity and then
his later life as a free man
my freedom is a privilege which nothing
else can equal he wrote
notwithstanding all the losses i have
suffered by fire by the injustice of
knaves by the cruelty and oppression of
falsehearted friends and the perfidy of
my own countrymen who i have assisted
and redeemed from bondage
i am now possessed of more than 100
acres of land
and three habitable dwelling houses
it gives me joy to think that i have and
that i deserve so good a character
especially for truth and integrity
the record venture smith left of his
singular life
shows the burden of suffering that all
slaves bore
when he was carried to his grave by his
pallbearers
two white men and two enslaved black men
they complained of his weight
venture outlived the three men who owned
him who had owned him but not slavery
itself
american slavery lasted for nearly 60
years after venture's death in 1805
but even after slavery ended on american
soil
northern dependence on slave-based labor
continued
throughout the 19th century connecticut
was a national and world center of ivory
manufacturing
so that affluent and middle class
americans could have a piano in the
parlor that badge of gentility as one
contemporary source described it
thousands of african elephants were
slaughtered and their ivory tusks were
carried to the continent's eastern coast
for shipping
african people were forced into
portraits and slavery to carry the tusks
sometimes as far as 800 miles
over a century
tens of thousands died on the coastward
track and survivors were often sold into
enslavement in the arab world
henry stanley said
every pound of ivory costs a human life
david livingston said
every tusk represented the death or
enslavement of five people
stanley was prone to exaggeration but
livingston who lived in africa for
decades was not
if you study the tons of ivory
transformed into piano keys in
connecticut
and during just 30 years of the trade an
estimated 400 000 tasks were processed
you come to some horrifying conclusions
about the numbers of african people
whose lives were disrupted or destroyed
so that americans could learn to play
the piano
connecticut began cutting keyboards in
the late 1830s and the last shipment of
ivory tusks was delivered in 1957.
the conservative estimates are that 2
million african people were affected but
the true number might be higher
our book is full of stories that are
horrifying to read yet necessary to
understand
once we know our true history
we can take ownership for it
and let it guide us
thank you
[Music]
we'll be pleased to take lessons from
the audience uh i'm sorry questions from
the audience but i would appreciate it
if um you would wait until the mic gets
to you so that everyone can hear your
question unfortunately we only have one
mic tonight because of the filming
i'm alice labrie and
i i heard mr dodson's lecture and he
touched on the subject also of the
british stopping the uh
slave ships
were there reasons to [ __ ] our
economy or humanitarian or what
you're talking about the illegal slave
trade area and uh at that point
as far as the united states was involved
it would have been
1840s
1850s it was totally clandestine and it
would have been to
try to end slavery it would not have
crippled the u.s economy most of these
slaves were being taken in the
first part of that time period to brazil
and later to cuba
it was like a drive as far as the united
states was concerned it was like a a
drug trade too lucrative to stop
my name is joan lapin i i'm curious you
said you grew up in rhode island and
uh you mentioned the brown family um
what
what was the situation in newport itself
in terms of how vital
to the to the
commerce that was going on there was
slave trading
this
lady asked what was the situation
specifically in newport rhode island in
regards to the slave trade
and
that quote i read the first wheel of
commerce
uh referred specifically to newport
newport was the center of the trade
before the revolution i do not have all
the numbers in my head but basically uh
pretty heavy
going from say uh
1750 to
1755 1775
numbers maybe 40
of all the
slave voyages launched from rhode island
occurred during that period
and
in the book which i can't open
there's a
great table i think
something like the
top uh eight of the top ten taxpayers
were either
investors in slave ships
owners of
refineries that made rum
or both it was
the big business in newport in that
limited period
um
given the
you know the extent of the complicity
that that you've documented and the
welter of information that you seem to
have
gotten your hands on
how do you explain
the fact that the
you know the national myth as as you
said before
has been so difficult to dislodge
why is it taking so long
to
get it right
right i mean that's a question we ask
ourselves
have asked ourselves every day for three
years
i think one of the one of the things
that helped us understand
this you know why some i mean many
historians and and black historians
particularly know this material
but it's it's it's not out there it
doesn't seem in the public yet
and
one of the ways that helped us to
understand it was to think about family
secrets
and that psychological model of the
thing that
you hope
uh will go away if you don't talk about
it
and we haven't talked about it
in a public way for so long that it
really did go away
um
um
we we
you know it
slay the extent
of our dependence
on enslaved people elsewhere
it it
disappeared
um it you know even things like the
triangle trade and and the provisioning
of the west indies which was you know
new england selling sending food down to
a place that was hell on earth um
it sounds sort of glamorous it's what
joel was saying about the traders and
that you know and cotton didn't look
like slavery and ivory pianos didn't
look like slavery and
none of you know harriet beecher stowe
it's the uh
uh front quote in our book she said
uh
actually oh
she said it better than i'm saying it
she said the northern slave holder
traded in men and women whom he never
saw
and of whose separations tears and
miseries he determined never to hear
we kept slavery at a distance
and so
you know
uh robert penwarin calls it the treasury
of virtue he said the northerners love
to think about how good they are and and
to take down that book from the shelf
and read wherein how they ended slavery
and he said there are problems with that
simplistic and interpretation
i feel like i got a little afield from
your question but maybe my colleagues
want to
[Music]
i wanted
i wanted to quickly add
that we all have different answers to
that very question
uh
i'll give you two quick uh possible
responses i was at a sim at uh
at the gildan lairman uh
center for uh study of slavery and
abolition at yale they had a symposium
symposium on reparations just last week
uh
i didn't exactly borrow it but one of
the people who
stood up
talked about the
public celebratory version of american
history versus the critical version
uh which
really has only started to emerge in the
last 20 or 30 years this exhibit right
here is an example
but the the
thing that one of the questioners said
that sounded so
simple and profound
when they were talking about how
the country might acknowledge slavery
this person said well if you acknowledge
it if you admit that slavery happened
the whole edifice of that narrative
comes tumbling down you cannot be the
country you thought
we thought we were
another
answer a way of explaining it is it
refers to this
treasury of virtue idea it's my thought
that uh when we talk about slavery that
you hear three
three different stories the north
stories the north version the south
version and the slaves version but
there's none that put it together and
that
single narrative is also what
explains why it hasn't been talked about
much
good evening
my name is peter allen harper and i
think we all want to thank the
historical society for bringing this
forward
so that the public can get a chance to
uh to hear to hear more we've heard a
number of figures and rounding up 40
percent here or
how new york would rot away the ships
would rot away can you give some gdp
figures can you give some numbers
about what you're talking about in terms
of
of
slavery and and what it meant for the
economy and
during various decades
buy the book
i happen to have a book right here the
whole evening is a tease
can we get some numbers
i wish i wish i had those at my
fingertips um
is there something specifically that
oh thank you joel i i
i have a favorite set of numbers
in 1860
uh there were about four million slaves
valued as property at three billion
dollars
three billion dollars was
as much as the total value of all the
railroads all the livestock
and all the machinery in the country
combined
i heard the same figure a different way
just at this
symposium david brian davis who's one of
the foremost scholars of slavery
said that
slaves were worth 80 percent of the
gross national product in 1860.
i couldn't believe it i asked him
to
how do we explain that and he basically
used the same figure
going into detail of how you calculate
gross national product then and now but
those are two pretty powerful figures
regarding uh august
belmont we still celebrate him with the
belmont stakes
and uh that's right august belmont was
the um an agent for the rothschilds in
the city of london
right and regarding the question the
lady posed about humanitarian and
british government
it was not humanitarian at all it was a
struggle between west indians and east
indians and this is not about black
people it's about financial interest in
london that was investing in cotton in
this part of country the world and the
east indians subsequently were
interested in developing india china
malaya singapore and so forth so it
wasn't humanitarian it was strictly a
struggle between monetary interest in
london
good evening um i have a question as i
teach a lot about
brooklyn and uh the slave trade in
brooklyn in brooklyn
being the largest uh
slave trading port in the state of new
york for a little pretty much most of
the time that slavery existed here in
new york state
and some of the families that jump out
every time i hear uh comments about
slavery here in new york i hear the
asters and a lot of the manhattan names
but
left out a lot of often is the lefferts
and the people that own the bedford
plantation and the lodge which has
become the bedford stuyvesant area of
brooklyn right now and i just wanted to
know if you do come across that and it's
really a two-part question and i never
hear much about new york in the
the 16th century in the 1500s we always
sort of start from the 60 early 1600s in
new york and we know now through history
that you know you had gomez and people
who were here even before francisco
verrazano is there much available about
new york in the trade in the 1500s
before the dutch the 1600s i mean
is that something
you know
let me answer
i'll handle or i'll make a a little stab
at the first part um about um other new
yorkers uh one thing that
and there there are so many studies
to be done i mean this is this is just
the beginning and and at one point one
of us should have said that um i was
fascinated to find that um
the bronx had a number of plantations
that van courtland park was a uh
plantation worked on by slaves
and there were plenty of other areas
there i can't identify all of them we
but there's a lot of work yet to do
and i'm gonna
joel i'm not sure if you can
it's not a complete answer if i
someone earlier said welter of
information that's uh welter is right
uh the period you were talking about
1500s 1600s
is not something that we looked at
uh
my memory from uh
reading about the slave trade at that
time it would have been more to
south america
it really
slaves being brought to north america
really didn't begin in a big way until
the
18th century
and uh
one of the uh
seemingly contradictory but interesting
facts is is
totaled maybe there were about
i think 700 000
uh slaves brought directly from africa
to the what is now the united states
who turned into 4 million that 700 000
is a small fraction
of the 11 or 12 million
africans transported in the middle
passage over four centuries
thank you
hi
um your the facts and the narrative you
give are very very compelling and i'm
wondering if you find
the historical
perspective relevant to
the myth
that we encounter today in american
society and i'm thinking of katrina i'm
thinking about the victims there and the
huge economic disparity between people
of african descent and white americans
people of african descent earned just a
fraction on the dollar of what white
americans earned for the same work with
the same qualifications and what i found
very striking about the narrative was
the reaction and the the the um
you told it in a very heartfelt way so
that
decades later centuries later we condemn
the attitudes of white americans towards
people of african descent and slavery so
we're able to see
the wrong-headedness of that sort of
thinking now and i'm wondering what
value you think your book your narrative
has
for
people of african descent today and the
economic disparity and the economic
relationship between
african americans in this country
well
i think we could all respond to that and
i i would be a marvelous discussion for
everybody um i i think uh
that
we all see connections i think it's
impossible not to
um
when you consider that this country has
had slavery longer than it hasn't
it's
it is uh
you would be naive not to see that there
are direct connections to uh the welfare
of black americans today and and what
they went through for what you went
through for centuries and centuries
i don't know if
i don't know if that
yeah
when we were working on the first
complicity project in our newspaper um i
interviewed uh james horton
who's a very well-known africanist
and he said you know if we had if there
had just been a system where we enslaved
people and we said we're going to use
your labor because we're bigger and
stronger and we can
he said i think we would have had a very
different outcome
than what we have ended up with which
was slavery and then this
basic you know the kind of things that
joel wrote about this this idea of
racial inferiority
and this science and this huge prejudice
that proved more lasting than slavery
itself
you know
i mean uh
and i've always remembered him saying
that
we ended up with something particularly
lethal
in the united states and i think it was
because of that system of inferior you
know this taught learn this
philosophy that black people were were
less
uh my question is and thank you for your
presentation over here
um as journalists how did your approach
to research and historical
interpretation uh how does it differ
from that of say
academic historians with you know sort
of formal training how did you become
interested as a group of journalists in
this topic and find and related to that
have academic historians neglected the
topic of northern complexity and the
role of northern businesses
uh
are you you're asking how we how we got
into this
is that is that
how our interpretation is different um i
think we were dumber
we we uh we
you know always considered ourselves
fairly educated people
and
we started getting into this more and
more and just every day we'd be coming
to the office going you're not going to
believe this you're just not going to
believe it gee anne did you know this
joel did you you know jenny did you know
and
we didn't know anything and um
i
i mean i i joke but in fact uh we didn't
have any preconception or our
preconceptions were was the mythology
you know
north good south bad
that's how it worked and uh you know we
had the underground railroad and and uh
harriet beecher stowe's house is
literally up the street from the
hartford current and you know we were
the good guys
so
i think in this case it was very helpful
not
knowing a lot in a way and being able to
walk into this as journalists and use
the same tools that we do on a daily
basis and just ask dumb questions and
and it got to the point that nobody
could answer them
so it was a whole different gestalt in a
way
i don't want to answer the question i
can see the people in the front so
wherever the microphone is i'm feeling
very bad about this gentleman right here
for one thing
but you don't know if you want to
respond
okay i was just going to respond to the
to the last gentleman
um
we really did use
as jenny said our tools as journalists
the tools that we have are gee that's
interesting or
who's responsible we were just guided by
our curiosity and it had to interest us
we all found and this was one of the
painful parts we all found really
interesting things that didn't get in
the book
because
it got a little there were
you know a certain group might be
interested but this was a group for this
was a book written for a general
audience
not for the historians who already know
a great deal it was written for
for
well
i mean it was written for us
because we didn't know anything
uh i'm going to take a wild guess and
say that i don't think you
that you considered new york to be in
the same category
as uh an occupied
uh city such as some people during the
civil war might have considered
baltimore to be and a city under federal
occupation
[Music]
basically pro south and its sympathies
but but because of its border position
and its proximity to washington
kept in mind by federal troops
uh i
guessing wildly that you don't consider
new york in that category
if that's true
i would ask you to enumerate
if you if you will
the
what must have been the overwhelming
business reasons for keeping new york
pro-union
and
and
abolitionists at least part in spirit
and i'm guessing that there must have
been enormous
uh you indicated the mayor's
1860 panic
and
and
a bunch of business leaders there must
have been another bunch of business
leaders who had overwhelming reasons for
supporting the union and if you could
address that
i can address that in part i i don't
think i can address that as thoroughly
as as as you or even i would want to i
think that there really did grow to be a
real tension between abolitionists and
the business community it certainly was
uh was definitely the case in uh in
boston and uh in northern new england
with the textile industry and there were
there were certainly new yorkers who uh
were abolitionists they were new york
businessmen who were abolitionists as
well and i think what happened was a
number
a number of things happened the fugitive
slave acts of 1850 really got a lot of
people angry um uh this the south uh
uh southern arrogance if you will got a
lot of people angry and i think there
was a real yin yang going on there and
sumpter obviously just put people over
the edge and and a lot of people came
together the morning after that
so
simplistically maybe business reasons
vying with
emotional and philosophical reasons
right
yes and with one once the erie canal of
course was built yes absolutely
i have to confess it's not an area i
know that much about with the railroads
but yes there was that going on as well
you're absolutely right
did the railroads have i'm sorry
no no he uh this gentleman was asking
about didn't the railroads have an
effect too with the westward movement
and yes absolutely people wanted to go
out there and and the big um the big
controversy of course was whether the
western states were going to be slave or
free and yes there was a lot going on in
that in that area too
i can't wait to read your book um and
you said something uh in conclusion i'm
paraphrasing you but it was something
like once we know our true history and
take ownership we can let it guide us
i'm wondering if you believe america
will ever
one apologize
or slavery
and or to offer some form of reparations
even if it's in free education for all
african-americans
in this country
if you think we'll see that either in
our lifetime or ever and secondly do you
have a website where you have maybe some
of this information that didn't get
uh in this lecture which i think is
excellent
um
we think of this book
as quite literally
a reparation it is literally a repair
to a history that is incomplete or that
we feel has been incomplete
we
jokingly talk about writing another book
and telling more of this story
as writers
we feel like that's our service
to tell this you know to tell this story
and then
to to begin if it can
some sort of national conversation or
many conversations
about
how to
make
our society just
i'm going to take just one more can i
just
i want to quickly respond because i was
at this uh
symposium on reparations just on
last friday at yale
and uh
one of the things that you realize as
you listen to a dozen different speakers
is how complicated a question it is
uh
what's the difference between an
apology how sincere can the apology be
if there's going to be compensation
actual monetary damages who should pay
who should collect one of the speakers
pointed out that
a lot of
i think you mentioned the present
population of new york city is almost 40
percent
first generation immigrants who can
hardly be expected to
feel responsible for slavery
several of them agreed the whole this
discussion of reparations
was shifting from a taught tort model
like law t-o-r-t
in which people expect to be made whole
to a different uh model that talks more
about reconciliation
uh
just one thing to think about that
struck me that i
think goes to this question of will
there ever be any kind of recognition
which has to do with our national
narrative
the difference between an apology
and uh admission of shame
an apology the way one of the uh
historians or
scholars talked about it means i made a
mistake
that is uncharacteristic of me
shame
is meaning i did something
that is reflective my of my character
that i don't want to admit is part of my
character
and that's where slavery that's what
makes it different difficult about
reconciliation because it's an issue
not just of an apology
but of
shame
i'm going to take just one more question
i know there are an awful lot of
questions but um ann and joel and
jennifer will be outside during the
reception
and um
is the last one
actually this particular leg
this particular lecture concerns slavery
within primarily within new york and its
relationships to slavery of the rest of
the various colonies
however you did not mention strongly
enough as far as i know the direct
connection of the original settlers who
are here who are directly connected to
the very ones who brought the greatest
numbers of slaves to the west indies for
their sugar plantations the britishers
the english
and they were all real primarily more
than 80
who were here who had those various
different prejudices and cruelties that
they continued and the prejudices which
continued with them what was the
commentary you have with respect to that
the
intention was not to
even assign guilt we were concentrating
on the united states we're aware that
the british
transported far more slaves than
americans did
one way to respond if ann can remember
it off the top of her head
is
uh
the
words the judge spoke at the sentencing
of nathaniel gordon uh which by the way
in response to this well where were the
abolitionists of course they were
abolitionists but it's interesting to
note that
when new yorkers
about 11 000 new yorkers signed a
petition to get gordon pardoned
so
it was
different
conflicting interest but anne remembers
the uh
the question of guilt that the judge and
gordon sentencing addressed
well
when nathaniel i this is um